[Música]
el ministerio de defensa ucraniano
confirmó que el ejército retomó el
control de la región de kiev al tiempo
que los ataques rusos ahora se centran
en el este la cruz roja informó que
avanza en la operación de evacuación de
civiles de mariupol y que logró
distribuir la primera carga de ayuda
humanitaria en irvine
la agencia espacial rusa roscósmos
anunció que enviará al kremlin las
propuestas sobre los plazos para el cese
de la cooperación en la estación
espacial internacional la decisión se
produce luego de que eeuu canadá y japón
mantuvieran las sanciones contra dos
empresas que envían suministros a la
estación analizamos en esta emisión
los candidatos a la presidencia francesa
realizaron mítines en el último fin de
semana de campaña electoral el
presidente manuel marrón llevó a cabo su
primer y único gran evento y alertó
sobre los riesgos del extremismo
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torres anchas y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en ucrania los militares
ucranianos retomaron el control de la
región de kiev tras retiro de las tropas
rusas así lo confirmó el ministerio de
defensa de ucrania esto al tiempo que
este sábado la cruz roja anunció que por
primera vez pudo entregar ayuda
humanitaria en irvine marina sardiña nos
amplía más detalles de lo que ocurre en
terreno en el siguiente informe
estos son los restos de la batalla por
la liberación de las inmediaciones de
kiev la capital de ucrania tanques rusos
calcinados restos de metralla en las
paredes de las casas en ruinas y el
silencio después de un mes del incesante
estruendo de los morteros rusos ir pin
el escudo protector de la capital y está
ahora bajo control de las fuerzas
ucranianas el saldo es alto
los ocupantes de rusos fueron expulsados
de aquí y están corriendo hacia belarús
por supuesto dejan muchos cadáveres
muchas casas destruidas muchos lugares
con trampas explosivas después de ellos
con la retoma de las tropas ucranianas
las organizaciones humanitarias
consiguieron entrar a la devastada
ciudad para entregar suministros
alimentos y medicinas a los residentes
que todavía permanecen allí
de chango se jacte by jav y fighting en
la ciudad se vio afectado por intensos
combates y vamos a distribuir alimentos
y a evaluar la situación humanitaria
creemos que puede haber 3.500 personas y
la prioridad es ver cómo es la situación
para ellos en este momento wade siete
visiones lightwater breakdown en la
localidad de busca al noroeste de kiev
la estampa es más aterradora más de
veinte cuerpos de civiles fueron
encontrados en una sola calle los
soldados ucranianos denunciaron que
estas personas fueron asesinadas por el
ejército ruso cuando intentaban huir
algunos en bicicleta
los bastardos rusos lo siento el tanque
detrás de mí estaba disparando
hemos sido ocupados estábamos rodeados
desde la ventana vi como los tanques
iban de una posición rusa a otra
entonces supimos que nuestro ejército
venía
la retirada rusa de las inmediaciones de
kiev deja un rastro de destrucción sin
precedentes pese a estar en manos
ucranianas miles de personas no podrán
volver a lo que un día fueron sus
hogares la inteligencia británica indicó
que los ataques dirigidos por el kremlin
se están concentrando en el suroriente
ucraniano mismo advertencia que lanzó el
presidente de volodymyr selenski la
región del donbass sigue siendo el
centro de los ataques y la segunda
ciudad más grande de ucrania kharkiv
también está repeliendo a las tropas
rusas pero recientemente en el sur del
país los avances rusos también han
golpeado las ciudades de mykolaiv y
enero dar
mientras la noticia de la retirada rusa
del norte de ucrania es buena para quien
la lucha se está calentando en otras
regiones clave en el este de nuestro
país la situación sigue siendo
extremadamente difícil los militares
rusos se dirigen al donbass en dirección
a jarque y se están preparando para
nuevos y poderosos golpes nos estamos
preparando para una defensa aún más
activa aprovechamos todas las
oportunidades tanto internas como
externas
los esfuerzos de rescate se han visto
obstaculizados últimamente concretamente
en las cercanías de mariupol donde los
convoy de la cruz roja han tenido que
renovar los intentos de evacuación
masiva pero atravesar el bloqueo ruso
sigue siendo una tarea difícil la
captura de la ciudad podría proporcionar
a moscú un puente terrestre
ininterrumpido desde rusia hasta crimea
en otro lugar durante el sábado un
cohete ruso habría impactado en una
línea ferroviaria en el centro sur del
cni pero mientras que en las primeras
horas varios misiles explotaron
alrededor de las ciudades centrales de
poltava y kremeniuk en la sellada ciudad
de mico life en el sur del país los
equipos de rescate a contrarreloj en
busca de señales de vida hace apenas
tres días los intensos bombardeos rusos
destruyeron parcialmente este edificio
gubernamental y se cree que murieron
decenas de personas y con la ofensiva
todavía a 30 kilómetros de la región
estratégica se espera que haya más
destrucción una serie de explosiones
también arrasó la ciudad de enarbolar
cerca de la central nuclear desde apoya
la planta responsable de suministrar a
ucrania más de una quinta parte de su
electricidad está bajo control ruso
desde principios de marzo también se
escucharon explosiones en las
inmediaciones del centro cultural sobre
menik donde los residentes celebraban
una manifestación en apoyo a ucrania
1325 civiles han muerto en la guerra en
ucrania esa es la cifra más reciente de
la oficina de la onu para los derechos
humanos a la lista se suma el
fallecimiento del fotógrafo maxim levin
un ucraniano que fue colaborador de la
agencia internacional reuters
el fotorreportero desapareció desde el
13 de marzo cuando cubría el conflicto
ahora la fiscalía ucraniana encontró su
cuerpo con dos disparos la entidad
responsabiliza a las fuerzas armadas
rusas dennis herrera tiene los detalles
la guerra arremete nuevamente contra el
periodismo el sábado se confirmó el
asesinato de un fotógrafo ucraniano su
cuerpo fue encontrado al norte de la
capital maxim levin trabajaba para un
medio ucraniano y era colaborador de
reuters entre otros medios
internacionales el periodista había
decidido ir al pueblo de emoción donde
hubo fuertes enfrentamientos este
asesinato se suma a la lista de nombres
de periodistas que han muerto en terreno
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa
brain renault fue el primero donde su
colega juan arredondo ciudadano colombo
estadounidense resultó herido
cruzamos el primer puente en irvine y
vamos a filmar a refugiados que se iban
nos subimos a un auto y alguien se
ofreció a llevarnos al otro puente y
cruzamos el control donde empezaron a
disparar en the stars ordenar a sus
reporteros sin fronteras ha informado
que desde que empezó la guerra dos
periodistas ucranianos han muerto y tres
extranjeros en el terreno los
periodistas expresan sentirse amenazados
todo el tiempo que hubo momentos en los
cuales pensé que mi vida corría peligro
pero creo que esto es la normalidad para
todos los colegas que en este momento
están informando sobre ucrania en el
terreno hay bombardeos a explosiones hay
disparos
eso que hemos contado nosotros lo hemos
visto con nuestros ojos las autoridades
ucranianas han informado que los
asesinatos se han dado a causa de los
ataques rusos sin embargo esa
información no se ha confirmado hasta el
momento por otras fuentes mientras
organizaciones de derechos humanos han
exigido a ambas naciones garantizar la
seguridad de los periodistas en medio de
la guerra
y la agencia espacial rusa roscósmos
anunció que ya está definiendo los
plazos para finalizar la cooperación en
la estación espacial internacional las
propuestas serán enviadas al kremlin y
se producen luego de que canadá estados
unidos y japón- mantuvieran las
sanciones contra dos empresas que
proveen suministros a la estación para
analizar este tema conectamos con diego
mardones él es doctor en astronomía de
la universidad de harvard y académico de
la universidad de chile- bienvenido a
france 24 la estación tiene un segmento
ruso que se encarga de los sistemas de
propulsión y un segmento estadounidense
que se encarga de la electricidad de los
sistemas de soporte vital en términos
prácticos que significa el fin de esta
cooperación hay posibilidad de
reemplazar el módulo de propulsión a
tiempo para mantenerla en órbita
depende lo que respiramos a tiempo es
muy difícil que sea algo inmediato
cualquier cosa del espacio toma tiempo y
no es sencillo
si es que no se reemplazará y dejarán de
actuar hay un plazo de varios años antes
de que la estación caiga de forma
descontrolada entonces en varios años si
es posible reemplazarla pero depende
fundamentalmente de la voluntad política
y en este minuto es muy difícil predecir
cualquier cosa bueno en los últimos años
eeuu tanto con la nasa como con empresas
privadas ha propiciado importantes
desarrollos en materia de envíos al
espacio por ejemplo spacex tiene su
cohete falcon line y su cápsula propia
que es la dragón en qué áreas se puede
hablar de interdependencia con rusia en
estos momentos
bueno tal como tú decías al comienzo la
estación necesita periódicamente una o
dos veces al mes
encender cohetes para levantarla un poco
porque va de a poquito bajando hacia la
tierra y eso tiene exclusividad por la
potencia de los motores en el módulo
ruso en este minuto si es que no
hubiesen iniciativas como las de spacex
no me cabe duda que la colaboración con
la unión soviética bueno con rusia
perdón seguirían en pie porque hasta
hace unos años atrás rusia era el único
país que tenía el
mecanismo de subir y bajar cosas y
personal a la estación espacial entonces
era absolutamente inviable romper
relaciones hoy gracias a todo el
adelanto de spacex y otras compañías
gringas se pueden dar el lujo de romper
relaciones y esperar arreglar el
problema dentro de pocos años
bueno y finalizar una cooperación de
este tipo claramente trae pérdidas en el
ámbito investigativo pero quién pierde
más eeuu y sus aliados o rusia
es muy difícil porque la pérdida es para
todos
mira las colaboraciones científicas son
entre individuos entre personas entre
laboratorios o instituciones y cuando se
dañan es muy difícil recuperarlo
imagínate que hay una prohibición desde
rusia o desde eeuu a por ejemplo no sé
yo trabajar contigo si es que después de
esto termina y se rearme en las
relaciones yo puedo seguir conversando
contigo pero la legalidad ya sea desde
rusia o desde eeuu es muy lenta de
cambiar y es muy probable que nos
prohíban conversar durante varios años o
quizás una década entonces los temas de
colaboración son muy sensibles y es
realmente una pena que se estén
rompiendo quién sufre más sufre más
probablemente el que queda más aislado
quién me imagino en este caso es en una
gran mayoría los casos serán los rusos
pero esa no debiera ser la pregunta la
pregunta debe ir hacer cómo hacerlo para
que suframos todos menos
pues señor mardones a usted muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlos con nosotros en france 24
francia se prepara para las elecciones
presidenciales el próximo 10 de abril
será la primera vuelta y en la recta
final los candidatos hacen sus últimos
esfuerzos para convencer a los indecisos
que son cerca del 37% de los electores
por eso gran parte de los 12 aspirantes
realizaron mítines políticos hoy incluso
el presidente el candidato es manuel ma
con quien no se ha mostrado mucho
durante la campaña
últimas oportunidades para los
candidatos franceses pero un primer y
único mitin para emanuel manjón en no
tener en las afueras de parís la
estrategia del presidente saliente para
convencer a los indecisos sigue siendo
la defensa de su balance
si estoy comprometido con el objetivo
del pleno empleo
[Aplausos]
porque gracias a todo lo que hemos hecho
juntos durante estos cinco años por
primera vez desde mediados de los años
setenta
nuestro país puede decir que en los
próximos cinco años alcanzará el pleno
empleo si es posible
del lado de la izquierda también hubo
mítines el candidato del nuevo partido
anticapitalista film habló frente a un
público de la capital cuando el
candidato del partido comunista fabia
juste la estaba más al sur cerca de lyon
su objetivo distinguirse de los demás
prometiendo atacar a la delincuencia de
cuello blanco
de edith hablemos ataque a la nunca han
querido abordar el fraude y la evasión
fiscal
uy pues para nosotros sí lo digo hoy y a
estas alturas de la campaña será una
prioridad aumentar el presupuesto del
estado reforzar nuestros servicios
públicos aumentar los salarios y las
pensiones
otra ciudad recibiendo un candidato
marsella donde erick se me visitó en
mercadillo ilegal
vean hay que limpiar esto físicamente
limpiar a la gente que está haciendo
todos estos tráficos enviarlos de vuelta
a su lugar de origen porque en su
mayoría son ilegales de cualquier
nacionalidad que sean hay que enviarlos
de vuelta a casa y no dejarlos aquí por
más tiempo
mañana otros cinco candidatos ofrecerán
mítines más traición típicas del winter
y acto en parís johnny que lanzó en
toulouse y son la sal en popa
clausurando un fin de semana de última
oportunidad antes de la votación del 10
de abril
en otras noticias la organización human
rights watch solicitó una reunión con el
presidente del salvador bukele para
tratar la situación de derechos humanos
en el país la solicitud se presenta
cuando la nación está bajo el régimen de
excepción a causa de la violencia que
dejó más de 80 fallecidos sólo durante
el fin de semana pasado un investigador
de la ong señaló el viernes que buque le
intimida al personal de la rama judicial
luego de que llamara al tribunal supremo
a remover a los jueces cómplices del
crimen organizado
así llegamos al final de este
informativo los invitamos a ampliar
todas las noticias en france 24 punto
com a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros que hay más en
france 24
[Música]